[Music]
service classes these are classes like
intro to philosophy or critical thinking
or ethics the kind of classes that we
don't teach primarily to philosophy
majors but teach to just about everybody
who goes to college the things you find
in what we call the core curriculum or
Gen ed I think those are among the most
important classes that academic
philosophers teach and I'll tell you why
in just a minute and I'll tell you why I
think it's important not just for the
students but for the wider world and for
the people who are teaching them first
before I do that I'm going to try to
boil down what I have to say in just a
few points for those of you who like it
short and sweet
[Music]
so what is it that I want to tell you
here about service classes from the
perspective of somebody who has been
teaching them for years and years and
who knows what other philosophers have
to say about them there's five main
things that I want to say although you
never know once I start going in the
rant I may have a few other things and I
want to roll in there so here's the the
five things in sort of a nutshell one
there's a perception that these classes
are easy that they're not valuable that
they're kind of slumming I think those
are completely misguided sentiments on
the part of those who teach these
classes or who try to get out of
teaching these classes to these classes
are extremely important because they are
the ones where we actually justify our
existence to the wide world outside of
our little domain of philosophy 3 these
classes are typically the one or if at
best you know two or three chances that
we get as a profession to engage
ordinary people and to produce in them a
you know idea that philosophy actually
matters by teaching these classes well
for these classes really are among the
most challenging to teach well they
require a lot of attentiveness to
audience and to continual improvement
over time and the fifth point that I
want to make is that I actually think
that these classes should be mandatory
for professors in my field to teach I
don't think anybody should be able to
escape teaching these it should not be a
reward that we give to people there's
good reasons for this a lot of which
stem from the practice of philosophy
itself so now on to the rant
[Music]
all right so here is my rant this is
what I have to say about this topic
which I have very strong feelings about
to begin with a lot of my peers do in
fact have the perception that these
service classes like intro ethics you
know critical thinking they are really
not valuable and they're easy to teach
just throw some stuff together and toss
it out there you know assign the
students some some readings make them do
some exercises and boom you get it over
with and now you can get on with the
important things in your day I think
this is a fundamentally misguided way of
thinking about not just those classes
but what it is that we're doing as
philosophers as you know pedagogical
professionals you know even if just as
persons and our ethical obligations
towards other people I think that these
service classes are the most important
classes that 99.9 percent of us have to
teach including the elite professors at
elite institutions who probably haven't
taught these classes for a long time
because they managed to get out of doing
it so I have a lot of reasons why I
think this is the case one of them is
that you know these classes aren't
actually that easy to teach when you get
down to it in order to teach them well
you actually have to work pretty hard
and I'll talk a bit more about that
later on and what the ramifications for
that are one of the things I want to
jump into right away though is if we as
philosophers particularly those who are
in the Academy are bitching and moaning
and griping about the fact that we're
not being taken seriously by people
outside of philosophy and that they want
to cut our budgets and stuff like that
unless we're actually kicking in and
doing our work to spread philosophy
outside of the confines of the
department and you know and it's classes
we don't really have any grounds for
complaining and I you know I know
somebody is going to have an
issue with my saying that and I'm
perfectly fine with with you know
defending that I think that if you want
to complain about philosophy and its
role but you're not doing a lot of work
to improve that you're part of the
problem not part of the solution and you
know if you think about these classes
these are the opportunity that we have
to engage the the wide world outside of
academic philosophy this is where we
have all the other majors in our classes
unless we made the the dumb mistake of
farming out ethics to some other
departments because we didn't want to
teach it which I have seen some schools
do a terrible idea right we should fight
tooth and nail to keep those ethics
classes and we should make sure that we
fill them up with business majors with
fashion majors economics majors you know
psych majors everybody from everywhere
so that we get a chance to introduce
them to philosophy to some rigorous ways
of thinking to some of the stuff that we
at least give lip service to being so
valuable you know you you want people to
read Plato teach Plato you want people
to think that Descartes is worth
considering teach Descartes right don't
just gripe about it teach that stuff in
classes to people I'm not saying that
this is the only way that we can reach
people I mean look at me I I do work on
YouTube right some of my peers blog or
even write for you know various
magazines and they they spread
philosophy that way you know I'm
constantly trying to find new angles to
bring philosophy to many other people
outside of the Academy but we ought to
be doing the same thing inside of the
Academy it's crazy for us not to be
doing that I'll tell you another thing
too this is really when we teach a
service class one of the few chances
that we have to reach so many people you
know in so many colleges there may be
just one philosophy class required
there may be two philosophy classes
required and those are the only times
when people are going to be doing some
serious study of that discipline unless
they choose to do so on their own I have
had so many conversations with people in
my travels in my conversations in
restaurants in you know trains all over
the place where I talk with them and
they find out that I'm you know in the
past a philosophy professor now I tell
people I'm a practical philosophy
because it's easy to bring a lot of
things under that head and they say I
took a philosophy class back in college
or when I was in university and I'll ask
them well how was it what did you learn
what did you think about it and they'll
say it sucked my instructor gave us all
this stuff to read and then didn't
explain it and talked down to us and you
know you know gave us questions that we
had no idea how to answer and then
didn't help us at all with that sort of
stuff or my instructor just turned into
one big rap session and we learned that
philosophy is just you know blathering
on about your opinion
ad nauseam the circle the desk sort of
stuff I've heard so many stories like
that I've also heard a lot of great
stories where people say oh my gosh that
was an amazing class that's why I
continued to go on and read some more
Aristotle or some more Descartes or took
another philosophy class but think about
how many students we have turned off
from philosophy by not teaching intro or
ethics or critical thinking to the best
of our ability not in a sort of phoning
it in showing up getting that class done
moving on to our real work our real work
is there in that classroom every one of
those those students who takes a class
because it's required not because they
want to take it but because it's
required they count just as much as do
the majors the graduate students are you
know professorial peers who are gonna
read our papers maybe if they get around
to it we have a unique opportunity given
to us
semester after semester to reach minds
and show them that the stuff that we
thought was worth going to graduate
school to study really is valuable and
you know all we got to do is be there
for them and explain the stuff to them
and design the class as well and give
them the kind of assignments that
actually help them to learn and grow not
just make work stuff alright that's what
I think we ought to be doing this leads
me to the next thing these classes are
not the easiest classes to teach these
are the most challenging classes I think
it's harder to teach an intro to
philosophy class well than it is to
teach some graduate seminar to some
graduate students true you need to
really know the topic that you're
talking about actually from what I've
seen with with you know some graduate
professors maybe you don't need to know
it because you can just send the
graduate students out to do some
research and you call it a seminar and
you have them present their stuff when
you have to take play-doh or decart or
[ __ ] or any of the great philosophers
Merritt you know Mary Wollstonecraft Han
Arendt and you have to explain it you
have to take those texts written in ways
that are hard to understand even
sometimes for us you have to explain it
to people who don't really have a
background in that and are wondering
what the hell am i doing in this class
if you can do that you're really a pro
that's where the the real teaching takes
place and that's not just a matter of
what you do you know when you get up in
front of the lectern that's what you do
as you think about the stuff that you're
rereading for the hundredth time and
you're trying to figure out where my
students gonna run into the most
problems and you're designing your
classes and you're thinking about what
kind of assignments are going to work
for them and you're answering their
emails and you're not blowing them off
when they show up in office hours when
you'd like to read your book or write
your article or prepare for your
graduate seminar these classes are the
hardest to teach to teach well there are
also some of the easiest classes to
screw up because you're working with
students that have you
very little background at all there
they're relying on you to get it right
to provide them with guidance that's an
incredible responsibility the other
thing I want to say about this I'm sure
that a lot of the things that said so
far are probably pretty controversial
and I'm willing to bet that I'm gonna
have instead of the usual comments that
that you know give me you know this
really wasn't on track coming from
people who aren't really that that you
know experience and what it is that I'm
talking about I'm sure I'm gonna have
some of my peers waiting and in telling
me I'm getting all this run but here's
the thing that I'm going to say service
classes should be mandatory for all
professors in philosophy I don't care
who you are you're not so important that
you couldn't teach one service class a
semester to undergraduates and you know
what I've seen really important you know
world class philosophers do this I've
seen some of them make a deliberate
decision to go and teach undergraduates
instead of just teaching graduate
students because they thought that that
mattered that's admirable in my view I
think that if you really want to become
a good teacher and you also want to you
know figure out whether you truly
understand Aristotle the test for that
is not whether you can explain it to
graduate students or get other
professors to say yeah you're on track
that was fine you did that when you did
your PhD you know the other professors
can give you Awards or whatever they're
gonna do invite you to write you know
chapter in their book but what really
really matters is whether you can
explain Aristotle to somebody who really
hasn't had much background in philosophy
and show them why Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics could transform their
life their career their relationships
reorient them to what it is that they're
doing in the world because that text can
do that or take Epictetus discourses or
take you know
I mean I've gone so far as to teach
Hegel in intro to philosophy classes
people say that's crazy how could those
students possibly be up to it well you
know these students will surprise you if
you actually put in the work yourself to
do it so I think that that we should
make this a mandatory part of you know
teaching for everybody across the board
I I'm sure you could get other people
behind it it would be very unpopular
among the professor it but it would be
so wonderful and there would be so many
of them who after a while would say oh I
get it I understand
I see why that was important some of
them would be kicking and screaming the
entire time all the way up till
retirement but others would also say no
there was a point to this exercise I can
say that myself is the last thing I'll
say from 20 years of putting in work
doing service classes or preparing to
you know other people to teach service
classes because I also coach other
professors I think it's really valuable
I think that you know we should be
reaching as wide an audience as possible
people accuse us of popularizing or
watering things down you don't have to
water anything down you can teach
ordinary people great philosophy but you
have to really work your butt off as an
instructor to do that and I think that
there's a lot of people who haven't put
in the time they could put in the time
I'm not saying they don't have the
talent they don't have the capacity to
do it but they haven't put in the time
to do that and so they write it off I
think we need to have a you know
transvaluation of our perspectives in
this sort of case so that's what I'm
going to close on that's my rant about
this time
[Music]